are there more home runs or more threes
in the NBA
Mike it feels like there we were so
one-dimensional let's ask this guy daryl
morey the Rockets general manager kind
enough to join us good morning Darryl
how are you good morning is Mario 3d
near one of the few guys you know I
started in baseball in the early 90s I
was given data to you and Keith way back
at ESPN from stats think yes I do
and I also know that what kind of
basketball player you were at sync in
1995 I actually I have I have your stats
oh my god okay here you go this is Daryl
Morey fall of 1995 three-on-three league
that he was in
I got you averaging 13 points per game
you shot 52 almost 53 percent from the
floor rebounds you did pretty well
assisted pretty well I don't know if you
shot any threes that year I would like
the Larry Bird of rec rec NBA YMCA bass
oh wow they couldn't move but could do
everything else it's I'm told you
attempted zero three-pointers in the
tournament that's to my a very strong
mid-range when you don't it changes it
changes the math of the game like if
you're not getting out going to the hoop
it makes going to the hoop worth less
open open stuffs worth more is there
different math used during the regular
season as opposed to the postseason in
the NBA in your a little bit a little
bit it's it's not as dramatically
different as people think but ya know
final calls go down for foul
you know defenses get tighter a lot of
that's related to the Falco yeah there's
you know generally obviously rotations
shrink so most players get a little
worse because they're they're the level
of competition goes up there's a few to
get better guys like James hard and get
better so yeah it's a little bit it's
it's different but it's maybe not as
different
people think what was your reaction when
you heard the Lakers pulled off the
Anthony Davis deal well one more
contender obviously there they're very
strong I mean I we were very confident
going into the next season and leave
most teams are scrambling the most
contenders are scrambling to keep their
five starters or put together their five
starters we got our five starters that
were the best team in the league down
the stretch and we're going to add a
mid-level that's going to get us to six
and we're pretty that's the worst case
and we're also chasing at least one of
these top free agents right now does
your philosophy change at all here in
the offseason after what happened to
Golden State with the injuries I
generally yeah it does a little bit in
the past we we knew like 90 percent plus
we've got a big old staple in the title
obviously those odds are a little
different and you know don't state does
force you to play differently you know
fives in particular have trouble against
against Golden State some of that stream
on some of that just all there off ball
switching that's very hard for five who
do you consider the best player in the
game who do you consider the best player
in the game that's right you kid you're
not allowed to compliment anybody
correct yeah it's sort of crazy I think
I think someone just got fined big money
for that they're either Doc Rivers I
think yeah he did he he said that Kawhi
was as close to the modern-day Michael
Jordan right yeah how much can you do
you want to change your team here in the
offseason so I think obviously we're
very aggressive actually you know what I
called loge after his story came out
saying we're changing everything and I
was like really is that news that we're
gonna be aggressive to try and get
better and do a trade if it makes sense
but I had to tell loads you he was right
it was news apparently you know
we've we've generated a lot of clicks in
the last few weeks for some reasons okay
but is that your you are everybody's
available or I mean explain what
aggressive means then in your
terminology I would say the main thing
is that were gone after one of these top
free agents and because of that it's
probably gonna have to be a trade so I
think you know anyone who knows the
overly complicated MBA if if you need to
you know if you need to if we're in our
position and you want to get a free
agent it has to be through sign and
trade so that requires a trade at some
point so that's sort of that's sort of
why there's a potential trade out there
is everybody available on the roster
know who's not available Chris and James
Chris Paul is not a long term deals all
of our rotations we got some good young
guys that have long yeah I was just
wondering if the Lakers called and all
of a sudden said hey you know what is
Chris available but you're saying that
no matter what anybody offers anybody
calls that Chris Paul and James Harden
will be in the backcourt next season I
mean again we're the best team down the
stretch we'd spent a lot of time putting
together two superstars we're trying to
add a third get on backwards from that
doesn't make a lot of sense for us how
do you recruit a free agent we wait
until the required moment by the NBA and
then we and then we talked but what are
you selling him on though oh that's easy
that's these obviously winnings number
one by far so that's that's a huge
factor then there's some great sides
we're the number one team in China in
Houston so you can become a global icon
which happens to all our top our top
players obviously we've got the income
tax advantage we got we're the second
best team over the last 25 years so you
know you're joining a winner's stable
organization you know I could go on but
those are the main points alright but
let's say I like to score how do you
convince me hey come on in and be the
SEC
third option here I would I would talked
about kevin mchale so when kevin mchale
is here we know a lot of free agents and
he talked about hey if i want to team
what we obviously have to Hall of Famers
why wouldn't you want to play at three
and he talked about how easy it makes it
how the game gets more fun you know it
it's a it's actually a positive thing to
have multiple Famers not and not a
negative thing so people make a little
bit too much of that my opinion do you
guys shoot too many threes no I really
it's hard to say that it I mean all
we're doing is shooting the same number
of jumpers that people shot in the past
we're just we're just stepping back a
few feet usually so it's really the same
I don't know why it's fine for people to
miss 18 footers but it's somehow a
problem when you're when you're missing
them farther out so I've never really
understood the focus on our first one
but Golden State it feels like they're
not shooting as many threes as they used
to
why is they they are shooting left less
they're a little like us with Chris Paul
Chris Paul's like one of the all-time
elite mid-range shooters but so are
multiple guys on the Warriors so I think
the best thing a coach can do is use
this personnel so guys like James and
Chris are good in the mid-range they're
obviously good from three two so we just
we're just trying to come down the floor
and score the most points possible often
that's from three most often it's in to
the line but sometimes it's the open
mid-range shot especially later in the
clock we're talking to Gerald Morey the
Rockets GM joining us Dan Patrick show
we love it you know every league is a
copycat league when we see somebody be
successful then teams try to emulate
that and now you have the Toronto
Raptors is is that a style that can be
emulated that's gonna be a tough Armas I
did an unbelievable job with aggressive
trades you know actually very similar to
what what we're talking about he did an
unbelievable job with bench deaths
obviously you gotta have a little good
fortune I talked to Messiah even he said
in that you know they need a ball to
bounce and to be silly
you got to have both you have a great
team which we have and you gotta have a
little bit a little bit of things go
your way
in Toronto to their credit had bolts and
what one thing I love about Toronto is
they turned around a lot of narratives
like you know there was a key player on
their team I can't discuss who's
considered a playoff Joker I knew he
wasn't because I knew him and and he you
know he had a massive massive layoff run
you know generally those narratives are
just you know people look at the result
find out what happens and then they
write their stories after and they try
to make it seem like everyone knew
before this his name rhyme with style
Bowery I know I have to go today one is
I love talking to you I don't want to
spend any money to Adam so no no and I I
don't I don't want you to get fined here
I'm also curious though you got D'Antoni
and do we have is there gonna be a
contract extension or can he just go in
you know with a year-to-year
contract on the big picture and that's
why I think it's surprising he's gonna
be back next year he's likely gonna be
our coach for long term we know we want
to work it out we're gonna work it out
an hour or after the season so I'm not
worried about it Mike's not worried
about it Mike was in the office
yesterday talking about everything how
we're going to meet with free agents at
the end of the day Mike's a great coach
and he's gonna be here I want at least
get your comments that there was a
report that there was a turmoil tension
between Harden and Chris Paul what do
you attribute that to do you agree that
there was and if so what do you
attribute that to I mean I don't know
how to label things that I would say we
have extremely high level competitors
both James and Chris and Mike and myself
and Salma Fertitta and none of us are
happy with over a candle emanated when
we had a good chance to win the last
couple years and you know that's gonna
when you do it multiple times in a row
it's gonna create some angst where you
know we're all trying to figure out how
to take that last step and we're not
always going to agree but we come
together and we went a lot of games I
mean I think there's
165 last year we were with 29 and 4 down
the stretch once we had our main
rotation guys in place so you know we
know what we do works we now want to get
it to work all the way to the finals and
you know that last step is what's in how
do we do it is what's maybe creating
some of the you know the the competitive
level we got right now yeah and I was
watching the roster and and I agree with
you I wouldn't break this up if you're
all-in and you're gonna try to win a
title in the next three years with Chris
Paul there it just felt like you needed
a mid-range jump shooter right I don't
know it felt like it was all or nothing
with this team later in the season in
the playoffs and I don't know how you go
out and say hey we're looking for a
mid-range jump shooter but it felt like
you missed that a little bit or am I
reading too much into it yeah I
personally wouldn't agree with that
here's the thing obviously we can use an
elite player that plays on three levels
and I think you know one of the free
agents were hoping the chase is like
that but you know for me that's not the
focus look there's this people forget
only one team win no one forgets that
but only one team wins and there's lots
of different ways to lose right but for
some reason some ways of losing is fine
like if you play a traditional-style
take over jumpers and lose that way
you're fine you're right plays the right
way you're fine and you're one of the 18
teams that they're you know they're the
12 teams didn't even make the playoffs
or fortunate right usually they're
playing a traditional style you know
just because we play different people go
like oh that wants him to play different
people everyone said Golden State
couldn't win till they won right I mean
I obviously your buddy Charles was a
pretty vocal about pretty vocal about
that but know no one who just shoots
threes to win and Golden State can't win
and then they wanted now everything
slips and as soon as we win playing the
way we do everyone will say it's fine so
I'm not if you win 60 games you can win
the title I promise you that's that's
been the rule throughout history and
then we won 60 we're on a 61 pace we
feel the mid level added to our starters
were 61 team we can win the title when
we win it obviously less than 50%
because that's true of every
next year but we feel like we're the
favorites in the West going in the next
season and that should be the story if
you had the number one pick in the draft
what would you take well I think I can
answer that no I don't think you have
any draft picks do you Darrell I'm just
gonna but I'm gonna be safe but the
consensus number one is very much the
consensus number one guys I don't think
that's a hard one of the easier number
one picks in a while I'm saying yeah but
you know RJ Barrett was considered a
better player coming out of high school
than Ben Zion good RJ Barrett being
better Pro than Zion Williamson of
course yes but I would say the odds are
pretty low I think you're talking injury
and potential and I think your talk yeah
I think it's hard I think it's hard he's
he's one of the all-time great college
performers at this point plus he has
elite athlete icism he'll be hit pretty
hard for him to not at least be you know
he's coming in with like high all-star
odds which is really rare you're talking
like 60 70 % chance of and also at that
one spot this year which is pretty rare
but you know Darryl I brought this up
that if I said let's say he's a
left-handed Blake Griffin and he puts up
these numbers that Blake has let's say
he's a 24 25 and 10 it feels like those
are Hall of Fame numbers it feels like
that will be a disappointment for Zion
Williamson or fans will look at this and
go oh yeah he's only getting penile 24
and 10 where's Blake Griffin is carving
out a Hall of Fame career and I look at
him you know Zion explosive like him got
to work on that mid-range jumper but you
know average in 24 and 10 that's that's
Larry Bird stuff you're right that it's
not the key will be what impact can he
make at whatever position ends up
defending primarily and if he can't be
at least an above-average defender then
you're right then he won't be one of the
top few players in the league like you
can't just be all offense you have to be
an impactful at least to an average
little defender I think he will be
but but you're right there have been
guys who have put up numbers and and
aren't an impact on defense and
therefore aren't good enough to fill in
the title do you think Hardin could stop
me if I had ten tries you shouldn't get
the ball on your way he's unbelievable
I don't know if you'll know he was like
ranked the number one on ball defender
in the league last year and I know you
know I know love people love their
narratives but
watch him on balls and and look up the
data he's he's he's honor is unreal it
was a yes or no question there Daryl I'm
just down here it you know yes okay I'm
answering counselor answer the question
instruct the witness yes you would not
be able to score on him I have fun in
the offseason
always great to catch up with you Darryl
thank you that's Daryl Morey the Rockets
GM for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]